long covet is very complex and it's
there's been a few studies done Dr Marty
McCary has written about this Johns
Hopkins researcher uh uh at the Wall
Street Journal looking at the best
studies on long covid and there's no
clear indication of you know infection
versus getting long coveted and the best
correlate that they found is people who
are prone towards wait for it anxiety
psychosomatic issues people more prone
to to worrying to overthinking things
and this is something that I've tracked
kind of in my own life as someone who
actually suffers from Mind Body issues
as they call it or or psychosomatic
issues meaning you experience symptoms
in your body whether digestive issues
chronic pains in various areas
tendonitis and it's not actually caused
by anything structural but it's caused
by deep-rooted fears and anxieties
there's this this fast literature that's
being um
Advanced more and more there's a great
book the way out by Dr Alan Gordon an
expert in in chronic pain and
psychosomatic issues right many people
who struggle with debilitating fear and
anxiety have severe digestive issues
tendonitis back pain is one of the most
common ones and the solution to their
problem is not back surgery or
physiotherapy
or you know medications for the
digestion but it's actually to reprogram
it the way reprogrammed the way they
perceive fear and the way that they
perceive
stressful situations in life and a lot
of that is due to you know traumatic
experiences and you know behavioral
conditioning from parents right if you
have parents who you know freak out very
quickly and are very stressed out then
you know children are going to be more
prone towards
experiencing reality in that same way
and experiencing these issues so so long
covet I'm I'm basically entirely
convinced is psychosomatic is a
psychosomatic phenomenon mealing meaning
it's for most people who are
experiencing symptoms for weeks and
weeks and months on end
the some of the root causes are actually
psychological rather than than physical
but again there's so much that we don't
know there's a lot of research that we
that we still need there was one study
that I I should look deeper into but
there was one study in France I believe
where they looked at long covid and they
they looked for antibodies and they
found that actually a lot of people said
they had long covid but they actually
um you know they weren't infected at
that point or they were infected a long
time ago or they had lower or higher
antibodies like it really kind of
um spread you know spread across the
Spectrum there was no clear like these
people had really bad covet or these
people had coveted recently and they
have long coveted versus people who
hired a while ago I mean there's there's
a lot of complexity there but but I'm
fairly convinced that it's a kind of a
psychosomatic disorder
foreign